hey everyone dear volo here and in
today's video i'm going to be going over
the impacts and the reality of jujutsu
kaizen's return to do this
i'm going to be going in depth on what i
see possibly happening throughout the
next few chapters and how the previous
xenon arc has impacted the jujutsu world
but before we get into all of that if
you
are new around here and want to keep up
to date with the latest jjk reviews one
piece reviews
one punch man reviews and tokyo avengers
reviews then make sure you hit that
subscribe button and leave a like on the
video if you do enjoy my content as that
really helps out with the algorithm but
enough of that let's get into the video
let's start off with maki and her zen
and clan massacre so i've seen people
disputing whether marquis mother killed
naoya and as silly as it sounds i
honestly think that he is dead in a
conversation between naoh and maki's
mother in which they were talking about
the twins the naoh said
may be pretty but she's unacceptable she
doesn't know how to support a man
any woman who can't walk three steps
behind a man should get stabbed in the
back and die
obviously we didn't pay much attention
to the foreshadowing but literally after
chapter 152
i think it's evidently obvious that he
has died from the wound so i see chapter
153 possibly starting off with the
confirmed death of naoya and leading
into the higher ups who were discussing
the possible removal of the xenon claim
for the big three
like we saw at the end of chapter 152. i
see it kind of just explaining a bit
more on what the higher ups know about
what's happened with the xenon clan and
its mass murder i didn't see them
realizing that it was maki and i feel
like they'll be completely unable to
figure out who it was probably assuming
it had something to do with suetogedo or
now known as kinjaku i've got this
feeling that all these higher ups that
we haven't seen yet will be revealed
especially if gege decides to take this
route of showing the impact of the
xenoclan's defeat and how they could all
be freaking out about the possible
collapse of the society they seem to
manipulate and control
when it comes to the rest of the group
we know that yuda has decided to head
into the so-called curtin and i guess
start collecting points although it's
possible we could go immediately into
more combat and get a bunch more action
with akotsu taking on a variety of
different people with varying techniques
i feel it's more likely that i'd say
this chapter and perhaps 154 as well
will be quite chill and more likely
information dumps so that characters can
catch up on the whole xenon ordeal learn
about maki and her newfound strength
and possibly more info on kenjaku and
this game master that we know so little
about if you haven't seen my theory on
the archangel system that i think
kenjaku has chosen then be sure to check
that out and i'll leave a link in the
description below as i feel like we need
to have one or two more new characters
that can fit certain roles of specific
archangels as we know gige does take
some inspiration from different
religions
folk tales and stories so i could see
him choosing to follow this judo
christianity path
and introducing to us the archangels
towards the end of this chapter i could
be completely wrong though and we could
have the entire chapter with yuji and
megami who are getting ready for the
culling game
perhaps megami's domain expansion is now
complete and we will get to see some
kind of hints at how he has improved his
skills and refined them to the point
that gojo would be somewhat impressed by
his growth with yuji i'm personally
hoping that he gains some kind of
technique for himself
so over these days before the culling
game starts to commence i can see him
possibly having an inner conflict with
sacona in which sukuna decides to teach
yuji for some reason how to use the
reverse curse technique and perhaps even
his malevolent shrine this is kind of
something i just see eventually
happening anyway
i don't know if it'll be because yuji is
a possible distant relative of sukuna
and has the genes to unlock these
abilities
or that his uncanny ability to pick up
new things and make them his own like
the black flash which at the moment has
kind of turned into yuji's ability more
than anything else
we've seen him use it a total of nine
times which is more than all other
character appearances that use black
flash all put together
so it would be such a development for
his character and also this inner
conflict he is facing musa kona would be
faced in some
way or another especially if yuji
expects to get stronger
it's like megami said we're just jujutsu
sorcerers they ain't heroes and people
die it's something that iridori
is going to have to come to a
realization with like he did in his
fight with mojito where he realised if
he actually wanted to help them then he
technically had to hurt and kill them to
put them out of their misery because
there was no possible way of reverting
them back to a human
there is still two or just under two
weeks or so i think before they have to
enter the curtain so if you think about
how it was 19 days that they had to
appear in the barrier since it was
initially formed and with maki and her
mini xenon arc i'd say it'll probably
skip a week forward maybe leaving us
with probably 10 to 13 days until they
have to enter the curtain
so to end the video off the reality that
jjk returns and completely blows
everyone's expectations as an extremely
likely possibility
i feel like once we get properly into
this culling game arc it's going to make
the shibuya arc look like the goodwill
event i feel like the shibuya arc will
still obviously be the first big arc but
after what i'm expecting to happen with
the current culling game
arc it's going to make people literally
freak out and these previous chapters
with the xenon family massacre is just a
little taster letting us know what we
are all in for but anyway
for now it's been your professional
degenerate diavolo and i'll see you all
in a bit
bye
[Music]